les plantes decker de rivières des
petits ruisseaux végétalisée tout ça au
bord d'une autoroute urbaine
depuis deux ans la rue papineau au nord
du métropolite air montréal a été
transformée en une mini centrale de
gestion et de filtration des eaux de
pluie dont on fait quelque chose de
nouveau dans un milieu qui est fortement
urbanisée pendant des décennies la
gestion des eaux pluie était loin d'être
sophistiqué au québec on installait des
normes collector des tuyaux pour se
débarrasser de l'eau le plus rapidement
possible la roche à l'époque c'était
l'eau pluviale doit aller au soul très
rapidement possible avec les
conséquences qu'on connaît donc
l'érosion des cours d'eau des
problématiques de refoulement des cours
d'eau qui réagissent très fortement lors
de pluies
donc c'est sur les conséquences de
mauvaise gestion ou de l'absence de
gestion de son client
montréal l'eau de pluie est directement
canaliser vers les aigus dans le débit
de guerre confort et qui déborde les
usines d'épuration ne fournissent plus
il y a alors une surverse le soulier est
pollué aboutit directement dans le
fleuve dans la rivière des prairies
avec le projet pilote de la rue papineau
l'architecte guy trudel veut changer
cette façon de faire mon idéal ça serait
que la ville soit comme une éponge enfin
avant le réaménagement la rue papineau
n'avait rien d'une éponge alsa été avec
un mail de béton de 20 m de large il y
avait je sais y'a même pas de trottoir
quand on a commencé de projets en 2011
on nous disait qu'elle collector était
déjà à capacité maximale au lieu
d'agrandir l'égout collecteur qui
déborde le conseiller en aménagement à
favoriser l'installation entre la rue
peel trottoirs d'une série de bassins
végétalisée il ya trente huit bassins
chacun des bassins sont reliés entre eux
et l'eau coule depuis la chaussée et les
trottoirs dans un plusieurs de chaussée
qui est standard l'os percole dans le
bassin et par gravité et de redistribuer
valdes à longueur de chacun des bassins
de 39
on veut simuler le cheminement naturel
que l'on pourrait faire à en milieu
naturel en milieu comme une forêt mais
en milieu urbain
l'idée c'est de retenir l'eau et de
l'air de la traiter et aussi de la
retenir pour poker aussi des surverses
c'est une pluie trop fort tu viens à
remplir le bassin des puisards surélevé
évacue l'excédent vers l'égout
collecteur sur l'ensemble des
observations qu'on fait jusqu'à
maintenant au niveau des pluies qu'on a
eu jusqu'à maintenant on a géré jusqu'à
95% des bonhommes d'eau qui ont tombé
sur la chaussée sur le trottoir dos et
de l'eau qui n'est pas allé dans le
collectif on n'est pas aidé encore ha ok
ça c'est important ça
voici à quoi peut ressembler de l'eau de
pluie qui passe directement de la rue à
un égout collecteur une eau grise noirci
et opaque l'eau qui passe par les
bassins de pluie de la rue papineau en
ressort limpide à peine jaunie par les
végétaux on se rend compte que l'on
finalement aidé pudeur alors qu'elle est
de meilleure qualité et que les bassins
ont réussi à diminuer le taux de
pollution est contenu dans l'eau ce sont
des végétaux qui résiste aux sels de
déglaçage etc des végétaux qui peuvent
résister à la sécheresse
parce qu'on se rend compte qu il peut
pendant un mois pour le voir ils ont
laissé la capacité contraire de pouvoir
résister à trop d'eau
en plus de traiter l'eau des plantes et
des arbres vont une fois à maturité
rafraîchir la température et limiter
l'étendue de l'îlot de chaleur ans ont
de l'argent parce que c'est très peu
coûteux d'affaires un type d'élevage
comme ça parce qu'on a sauvé
probablement des coups de pas avoir
reconstruit un ouvrage est pas structure
grise donc le gros tuyaux souterrains on
n'a pas eu à la faire
c'est seulement depuis 2012 que le
ministère de l'environnement oblige les
villes québécoises à mieux gérer l'eau
de pluie cette façon de voir la gestion
des eaux pluviales n'était pas dans nos
moeurs puis maintenant elle est
obligatoire justement à cause de tous
les évènements convient un peu partout
marcel roy est un spécialiste dans la
gestion des eaux de pluie deux critères
qui sont super important gestion des
eaux pluviales le premier c'est la
qualité donc la qualité vont être gérés
via une infrastructure comme on va voir
comme par exemple sur la rue papineau
saisir un jardin puis par exemple est le
deuxième point qui est important c'est
le volet quantité le seul les 38 bassin
d'habitat pinault ne pourrait pas
contenir un déluge une puissante nerfs
on aura donc toujours besoin des grands
et aux collecteurs mais en multipliant
ce genre d ponge verte partout en ville
comme l'espère guy trudel
on pourrait au moins évité d'agrandir
constamment les immenses tuyaux
souterrains qui servent à gérer l'eau de
pluie ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal